les garçons nous en avons eu un autre mort les
gens disent qu'une femme a été vue en train de fuir la ville
la fille correspond à la description de notre vieil
ami Jane
nous interrogerons chaque âme vivante
retourner chaque rocher jusqu'à ce que ce serpent Slough
soit en vue quand elle fait bien vous
apportez  moi votre tête
j'ai besoin d'un flingueur ils devraient
venir des garçons pour vous n'avez pas besoin d'une arme à feu monsieur vous avez
besoin d'un [ __ ] de régiment
il y a tellement de choses que vous ne savez pas après votre
départ
Bishop's a offert une protection pour moi et
ma fille ils avaient d'autres intentions
alors  bizarre un seul chemin dans un sens
j'ai couru toute une vie ils viennent
chez moi je vais le
protéger  ça fait des années que l'homme paie pour
tout ce qu'il prend tu sais différent
je ne t'en ai plus parlé
je veux qu'elle revienne en ma possession où
elle appartient d'
accord
il regarde Fletch et je vais te faire exploser
la tête